scott
[Laughter]
don't start none won't be none
yeah you idiot chris evans didn't waste
any time getting revenge on his little
brother
scott evans for pulling this simple yet
epic prank scare on him in a video
shared to instagram
over the weekend chris
got plotted against the avengers in-game
actor by hiding around the corner as he
entered the house
with his beloved dog dodger
he captured his superhero brother having
an adorable chat with the pup
and then it was game on
chris scaring each other with the sound
of their own name
is a trend for these brothers
back in november they documented the
pranks they pulled against one another
over the thanksgiving holiday
[Music]
what can you tell us about your brother
that people don't know about him
he's hilarious funniest kid i know well
a good sense of humor
and interest in pranking must run in the
evans family
in 2017 chris appeared on jimmy kimmel
live
and opened up about a crazy april fool's
prank
his parents played on him and his
siblings
i was 10 and i'm one of four and my
parents sat us down at dinner and told
us that we were all
gonna move to london we had to my father
got transferred
and we all got to move and we started
bawling everyone's you know
crying at dinner and they kept it coming
the whole dinner probably for at least
an hour
well when it comes to chris and scott it
seems as if
these prank wars are going to continue
for some time
god